put it down put it down now I just want
to try put it down right put it down
[Music]
so it's maybe have these little kitchen
gadgets and we are going to try to match
them to the correct item on the table
these are like crazy food product yeah
what object is used on which food
there's a lot of phallic and non phallic
object this for bagels but we don't have
any bagels here it looks like there is a
cylinder cue logos in it so that narrows
it down put it let's go see I think I
got this right away
okay you know how it's so hard to get
the table off of the corn you just put
it here and you cob it off I don't think
that's right this way like oh oh wait if
this is not what it's for then I'm a
genius
[Music]
you know when it's really hard to dunk a
cookie because you don't want to dunk
the whole thing well now we've got the
cookie dunker no no no no no no that
seems like a horrible art world right
but it doesn't write as a spoiler it
kind of looks like somebody cracked an
egg well now we're gonna
oh I mean it did slice a grape into
small amount that one is for what then
why would you slice a great like that so
we had a lot of questions about it would
make a lot of sense
same thing pirate this is full blown
mine that's what it's for I figured it
out I can go home now it is nothing it's
like a cheese with it I think it might
be for the Oreos Oh to dunk it yeah that
that is what the cookie dunker is
yourself you're gonna use it maybe once
and then lose it and then putting next
time you have Oreos you know like man
where's my Oreo dippers oh well I'll
just use my hands
okay look like a beautiful jewelry my
earrings or rings or something what is
go with me you put mustard on this one
and you put ketchup on this one and you
light it down the hotdog spiral eyes I
don't think this is is this correct this
doesn't seem correct why would you want
to spiral your hot kids and [ __ ] then
this hot dog is cut before the kid look
at that that is all right I would rather
have it on like a like a spinny thing
and then just have a knife like this I'm
an inventor now we made a Miss I'd like
the one thing we did here today was
literally completely make them you need
to do that this is why I don't cook
and this why don't have kids
[Music]